as you know the date yesterday was ah
better than the last class it was twelve
thirteen fourteen so they had a chess
tournament here called open right okay
my covers are genius okay so I played
the tournament and then they kept giving
me money twelve thirteen fourteen and
they never stopped no okay so I had a
funny tournament and round one I played
a 1500 how did I do origin right but was
I totally lost yeah that's getting
crushed okay then I was like I should
play better than this I played better
the rest of the games alright so I have
two rules I tell my students and I broke
them every move this game yes that's why
I was losing I just want to see if my
rules were right okay now I say never
sacrifice
you should sacrifice your opponent's
pieces right okay I sacrificed upon g4
now I have made a video on this moves I
should know something about it I should
and he didn't take he took this pawn and
now I made a mistake because I made a
lot of mistakes right
that's a good question if only this
class knew that would be a mistake
good job yeah now I took the pawn I took
the wrong way I took with a queen yeah
yeah she did was a knight because
everybody else did okay so he took a
pawn like my comer he did this BAM
now unlike most of you I developed a
piece here Bishop f4 yay
well that would be on the side boo
okay then I retreated and then I we
traded now I made your favorite move
castles yay okay now in this position in
this position I made a terrible move
okay
notice my bishop on g5 is sort of
threatened so I could take the bishop or
retreat to e3 I made the wrong decision
as usual and I have a rule never trade
so I traded after Bishop e3 the computer
says whites better because his Queen's
on e5 I'm going to go here rawr so I
should have done that now he made the
least likely move of the three normal
moves that gives it away King tapes
that's the best move because if he takes
with something else I'll take this pawn
or I'll play f4 they're both good but
King takes defends the pawn that wasn't
nice of him now most of you would play
f4 here then they would take on F when
you go oh yeah so I didn't do that
notice he has two pieces that are
defending f4 now and I only have one now
Arjen what's my rule never and ever
sacrifice so did I sacrifice I did
the reason I can't play f4 is his
Knights defending it I took his knight
why and he's like he's like thank you
and then I played a four yes now his
queen is attacked you agree and also I
have a battery queen and rook attacking
his d6 pawn so if his Queen moves to
some random square I don't know here
hanging then Shaq and checkmate now some
of you some of you would play Queen c5
because that defends the pawn queen c5
losses for two reasons
I can play normally 9a for attacking his
queen and now his queen can't defend his
D pawn ah or I could play crazy B for
recommended by James IV uh no comment
okay now if Queen takes pawn raise your
hand who finds the winning move for
white highly recommended by me did you
find it at home yet ah does white win a
queen winning a queen is good if you're
taking notes write that down yes
yeah you in correct
you see when you raise your hand you
know the answer don't raise your hand
and think for five hours
yeah ninety five check attacking the
king and attacking the queen by
discovery so white yeah so he didn't do
that he played Queen f6 now I blundered
again because I want to be consistent
that I played e5 and my reasoning was
which was wrong reasoning if he takes
what she did I was going to play Knight
e4 attacking his Queen and also his
Queens defending here so my queen can
come down and made him but I forgot he
could just play Queen takes pawn
and I can't move my Queen down and made
him because my Queens pinned so the
computer won't let me play Queen d6 it
puts it back on detail because then I
would be in check now if we trade Queens
I'm down a lot I'm down in exchange in
several pawns but we have to trade
Queens because my Queens pinned so that
what I did now I took on e5 and he took
with the Queen who has more material
who's ahead white or black black but I
was white okay but I didn't lose yet not
yet because his King is no good should a
castle and these pieces didn't move yet
so maybe I have a chance he has he has a
rut and two pawns for a knight hmm
wonder what's worth more right so I
better get some pieces back right okay
so I played Bishop c4 because I want to
win his queen
exactly ah rook e1 so he lost his queen
and resigned now he didn't do that
computer says he should play King f8 but
he played what did he play Queen c7 then
I put him in Shak but he saw it and then
I played Knight e4 to play Knight d6
check yay what an attack and now he
castles right but in the 1 o'clock class
they're like yay Castle high-fiving each
other
yeah computer won't let me do it because
he moved his King twice when can black
castle raise your hand yes
you know didn't she read your lines I
emailed you last night game in this game
at this point in time when can black
castle later when when the next game
starts yeah not this game right okay he
played rook h5 I wonder what that does
but I saw it
now I'm threatening double discovered
triple quadruple check right yeah Knight
f6 double check so for example let's
play a bad move double check right and
then me is that what happened
he played Queen e5 now most of you are
thinking wait a second
why can't she win a queen with 96 check
and then take his queen the reason is
his rooks defending his Queen true story
so I played Bishop e2 hoping his rook
would move away and then I can do that
but he didn't fall for that
he played f6 defending his Queen again
how am I supposed to win his Queen he
was defending it now who's ahead white
or black black is ahead two pawns now i
blundered my knight with this move
oh no he could take my knight did he
take it
no if he takes my knight what do I do
wow that's the worst move ever that was
the worst that's the worst typo ever
rook e1 BAM
did he play Queen takes Knight he still
did he still didn't he played Bishop e6
which is okay and should I play Queen
all the way to the back row check now
because I know Castle and take it no
he'll know so I play Queen before and
finally he started wandering it took him
long enough I'm trying to win over here
blacks winning if he saves his be pawn
with b6 then he's two pawns ahead but he
played Bishop to d5 attacking my knight
did I see it check and now he made a
losing move he should play King f8 and I
guess black slightly better its equal B
play King d7 and he did something you
should never do in chess and you should
never do in real life he walked into a
fork ow
do you see the fork anybody anybody
nobody sees it people with their hands
up don't see it Queen takes pawn Shaq
winning his rook okay now when I give
endgame lectures I tell you to Queen
your pawns promote your pawns to Queens
and you guys are like I don't want
that's hard okay now I tried to fill my
pawn he tried to promote his we both
promoted were the best so he played f5
he's going to play F for f3 f2 f1 and
then I took his 8 pawn so I could play a
4 a 5 a 6 a 7 let's see who won man look
how good we are phoning our pawns now
he's a little closer than me isn't he f2
f1 he's getting close so I gave him a
lot of checks and if you know me those
checks weren't good okay and then I took
his queen hooray for me
but he's even closer to queening No
your rocket friends aah aah that's what
you would do that would be a good move
yeah I don't do that I actually actually
had a better move okay I thought really
far ahead and I realized I should
sacrifice again okay because see my pawn
that's going to queen is his king and a
stop it what could stop it
the bishop oh wait there's no more
bishop okay now in my one o'clock class
they suggested he should Queen here
I'm serious yeah they did and I was like
you're in shock and they're like oh but
but but if black was not in check that
would be a good move I raise your hand
what's the only winning move for white
white has one winning move who can find
it wait I know a six is risky because he
promotes to a queen with checkmate so
that is winning but for the wrong person
yeah King the g1 is illegal because I'd
be in check by his pawn it's still
better than a six
what about it now is that pong going to
Queen or not going to capture it what
about my a pawn on the fifth rank over
there on the side let's let's figure it
out came here King here hurry for me
okay so instead of letting me Queen he
did what you'll never do he resigned
yeah now I'm going to Queen and he won't
well that was my toughest game and he
was rated 1500 and my rings like 8000 so
there's like so there's like a sixty
five hundred point difference there
right Arjen fed you a good math there
what is my rating
yeah someone get this kid a TV what'd
you say approximately now now let's pay
attention to some math here I played
four games in this tournament and I won
four games
how many rating points did I gain you
then that would be awesome if you were
right that would be awesome
the correct answer is one one one year I
was actually happy I gained one I
thought in zero serious that night and I
couldn't yeah my opponents were slightly
low rated than me slightly okay now I
beat somebody else that games too long
okay this game I like because I won
although it's spending a lot so maybe I
don't like it that's good what it's
spinning a lot
it says not responding now it's okay
yeah okay now I said the lecture would
be in French and I wasn't kidding
see hey two of you got it that was good
what's the name of this opening there
you go yeah it's sort of weird yeah well
it is French so anyway so in this
position I made the most unusual of
moves I made the position totally
symmetrical where everything was the
same how did I do that
what
what move that makes it totally
symmetrical someone teaches kid what
symmetrical means yeah everything is the
exact same no I took and he took back
now that's symmetrical right okay and I
played here and he copied me and I
raised my hand and I'm like Mike comer
he can't copy me is that what I did yeah
yeah by the way if your points copying
you is that allowed if you think the
answer is no I got one thing to say to
you
one o'clock class all right
so I played C for an explosive move you
could still go get that joke
okay then he checked me but I saw it now
in the one o'clock class they were like
checkmate that's it and I was like wait
a minute what why can't I just move now
unfortunately the suggested move in that
class was King e2 after King e2 it's
hard to Castle I could still Castle
magic Grandmaster was hard okay so did I
play King e2 if you play king e to a
class do you go - yeah I played Knight
c3 and now he castled like you guys do I
develop my bishop I develop my other
bishop we traded pawns we traded bishops
and I castled now he played one bit move
after another that's good you know why
he's playing me yeah now in your
professional opinion as a two o'clock
class so your opinion matters should you
put your pieces in the center or the
side is that what he did he's higher
rated than you shouldn't he know that
he's rated 1900
you're all waiting to Eternity better
there that's that that's more boy than
any store I've ever told and all my
stories are boring so that's you know
you got to come lecture then no okay
that show got laughs laughs to my jokes
all right first of all your rating is
not zero your unrated you don't have a
reigning not you the story you told
and then he be players I got 1500 come
on that's everybody in this class is
1500 right Arjun okay see he agree with
my lies so they're true okay
we call that I see her public and party
I can't say that yeah well I said it
okay give you some editing to do alright
so I he played nine to a six is that
where the night goes in chess if you're
playing me maybe okay
I played Queen b3 and he made the losing
move which is good because I was playing
him he played Bishop f8 and he was like
he if he takes my pawn that's what he
was hoping then he would attack my queen
and if I take his Knight he would take
my queen and if I don't take his night
that his rooks coming down and probably
we would repeat forever you see what I'm
saying
where else is as well as my queen going
to go right where else know we're safe
right
I asked Dustin Hoffman several times
there's nowhere safe to go now did I do
that and we drew was a draw game that's
what I want
no so this position I realized his rook
was overworked and I know overworked
right Bensimon okay his rook is blocking
like Queen in the diagonal and it's
defending his night so I attacked his
rook you see how my Knights attacking
his rook right and you guys are like so
I move the rook I dare you to move the
rook
move the rook and I'll show you why it's
bad yeah I'm going to play Queen takes
f7 check which I did but he can defend
f7 with rookie 7 I have a question is
this rook defending his knights till now
so now I take the font and now he cries
because I don't I don't know what he
does here you guys know what he does
plays why then you're hanging your rook
in the corner don't do that ok he didn't
like that so after Knight g5 he's
actually losing ok and we're only I
moved 13 he played rugby 6 because
that's where your rook goes in the
opening I took now I want my Knights to
go to f7 because I want my nights ago to
have 7 you know what I mean you see what
I'm saying
can i play 9s 7 not right now because my
Queen's there so I've moved my queen
away now I can find that f7 however I
still can't play 9 f7 because it's not
my move I wish it was then I would win
his Queen and made him so let's play a
random move did you do Shaq most of you
would take the Queen what I don't double
check see how it's double check then I
would check I wonder what he would do he
would take and then mate
oh he went a half what I like it okay so
he played Queen e7 and now it is shocked
to mic comer and Spencer I played the
best move and none of you would ever
think of this move ever and when I show
you the move you'll be scratching your
head confused okay now I don't have a
force twin I can't do anything that wins
so when I don't have a force twin I try
to look for my opponent's good moves and
stop them
okay that's why when I play you for fun
you guys have no good moves I already
stopped them my opponent has a terrible
night and a terrible wreck but they can
both go to be for now the Knights good
now the rook attacks my queen right so I
played 83 and now he can't do that then
he cried also if he wants to take a free
pawn and I attack his rook somebody
suggest a safe Square for his rook
that's there are no safe squares because
I played a3 he could fork my queen my
queen and night and now I play Queen c6
attacking everything right that's a
triple fork so he didn't do any of that
he played h6 attacking my knight but I
saw it and then he attacked my queen but
I saw it and I attacked his rook yeah
but is that going to help him that he
saw it raise your hand
working that rook moved to safety it's
not easy not easy c6 is safe okay but
then you walk into a fork so he played
rook v3 is that where your rook goes in
the middle game by the way these are
pretty good
okay so I played rookie 1 I'm going to
get it as Queen and then I got it as
Queen see how his Queens attacked by my
rook he moved it I attacked it again
then he moved it and I did the winning
fork raise your hand
what's the winning fork for white
probably involves this piece here that
looks sort of silly you Queen C for
attacking the rook and now this piece is
attacked twice so he played rook takes
Knight and this position is getting sort
of silly because he's done a lot of
material and this position he resigned
after he moved I didn't get a chance to
beat him he resigned I give up okay and
then I'll show you a funny checkmate
that didn't happen because he gave up I
would have played Shaq and he would have
gotten a check let's say here then I
sacrificed my bishop threatening
checkmate and checkmate
so he's like thank you and then
checkmate so that could have happened
you see how he has good defense of his
king wait a minute those pieces aren't
near his King at all oh here's a lot of
pauses for wait a minute where'd they go
but but you can't blame him he played
that great Knight a6 move he showed me
knight on the side of the board yeah I
don't think his pieces are cut up on the
Queen side or making his King safe also
I'm up a rook for a knight and I have an
extra pawn too and that was my toughest
opponent so I'll tell you a funny story
you know why I like stories a month ago
that guy beat a Grand Master a Grand
Master's better than me so you know
watch these guys tough right he wasn't
so tough this game but he was tough that
game right here be talking yeah it was
Fidel Corrales your favorite player
nothing
you know everybody else does know they
don't know either even at home they're
like what if a dolls wife is like who
that his babies like what okay yeah he's
a baby he has a new baby as of like
three months ago okay now if you thought
the lecture was in French that's because
my last opponents saying was French true
story
okay and I was black and he had three
out of three
and I had three out of three so whoever
wins will have four now if you're a
super Grandmaster like Anand that you
draw all your games when the last one
you win the tournament if you play
upstairs with 12 13 14 open you got to
win all your games we're tougher around
here okay I was black and the critical
part of the game was in this position he
sacrificed a piece you see how my
Knights attacking his bishop he didn't
do anything about it he traded Queens
and then he played rook d1 and I thought
for 20 minutes just like you guys do
yeah exactly right okay so I was
thinking trade the rooks and take the
piece yeah I have a piece up but I
didn't do that
although computer says I should now he
plays rook here check what do I do
yep then he goes here I went to this
position in my head for a long time and
I was like I can't figure this out now
why he wants to play Knight to d7
yeah and also my bishops pinned and and
white wants to play Knight to g4
threatening Knight h6 checkmate
so black only has one good move here
okay
black on action Oh black has more than
one good move I can move my knight and
then when he threatens checkmate I can
play f6 so it's not checkmate although
I'm giving this pawn away and my bishops
pinned I didn't like that so I was like
I want Michael and do that so instead of
taking a piece and getting in trouble
I played rook here then we got a really
boring position black has the advantage
because black has two bishops or as they
send the one o'clock class huh right
right Ben
okay so nothing happened
nothing happened nothing happened okay
that's like a lot of movies you guys
watch nothing happened
okay then my opponent went crazy okay
Prince style okay instead of nothing
happening he went our our it opened his
King up and then I attacked his King
he played g4 now his Kings not so safe
so I attacked his night and he retreated
why did he retreat was Ames French okay
now I attacked h5 let's open up his King
okay and now I wanted to put my rook on
the H line so I jumped over my bishop
right now I'm not allowed to do that so
I played it I played Bishop e7 and then
my rook went over there here come my
rooks and he was like hey your rooks are
coming over there I'm going to take a
free pawn BAM and I was like you can
have your free pawn while I meet you
okay okay now I made a mistake because I
missed his defense I should have played
Bishop c5 the reason is I'm attacking
this pawn the reason I'm attacking this
on as this night is penned you see how
the night spend if he defends his pawn
now his bishops on d2 not on a5 during
the game on light so but then when you
play that was like oh I missed the
defense that he had I played Bishop e6
attacking his Jeep on which has no
defense and after here I'm like whatever
and now his bishop on a5 is good
he played Bishop c7 which I didn't see
that attacks my rook and now his bishops
pretty good pretty good Bishop right
okay and now my rooks trapped so he
attacked it you see how my rooks trapped
but I have 700 passed pawns coming so he
didn't like that I sacrificed and then I
attacked his rook he moved it then I
went here and his pieces can't move this
can't move this can't move and I'm my
pawns are queening I'm going to play
Bishop here Jack and then Bishop here so
now he did something really funny it's
funnier to me than you much funnier to
me than you he played before and he
offered me a draw okay and after the
game ended I put my game on the computer
and I said who's winning here it said
black is +5 so the computer thinks black
is like a rook up so probably I'm not
going to take a draw right I'll take a
draw if I was - I won't take a draw okay
so I checked him but he saw it and then
I played here now his rooks really good
it's all comfy
also his night's good it can move to a
lot of squares now okay he played rook a
three and I was very confused because
every move wins for me I was like that
wins that wins that wins I was so
confused so I played rook h1 that's one
of the winning moves where does his
Knight go to safety
good good answer yeah if he plays rook
k1 defending his Knight which he didn't
do I play III check well now his King
moves away from his Knight because he
has to or I could play Bishop h3 also
winning or I could do any legal move
also winning so he sacrificed his Knight
and I took all of his pieces we call
that magicians chess his pieces
disappeared okay and what's funny was an
elephant showed up and that in the
tournament room so I took the pieces
away and I made an elephant appear as a
good magic trick okay so I took his
night and then I took his rook and then
I took his under Rock does that rook
have a lot of safe squares now he's down
to bishops now at my level you know when
you're high rated and you're up to
bishops what is the other guy do
resigned did he resign he cried and he
kept playing he kept going he kept
trying was he successful
yeah not he resigned he's like okay I'll
come down to bishops diet loses all of
his pawns actually computer announces
made here computers are good it's like
mate in 14 yeah well he there's almost
no legal lose computers are good at
those positions when there's for you
legal moves they're still okay but they
don't announce made yeah so that was the
last round and what was the best part of
the last round there see there you go
that was better than my answer yeah then
you go and get paid right yeah now I'm
gonna tell you a funny story there was a
guy in the tournament rated about 2200
and we were going to win all our games
and play in the last round for first
place he was like hmm that doesn't sound
good does he want to play me in the last
round
because then he might lose so he did
something that is allowed in the Chess
Club in the most tournaments took a
half-point buy and you have to tell them
before round two he was like I win I win
I win and play fine gold in the last
round I would like a half point by so he
won his first three games he didn't play
the last round so he got how many points
three and a half how many did I get four
let's say we played in the last round
and I won then how many points would he
have three see he got second place he
didn't play the last round and I beat
his competition you see what I'm saying
so he was silly but he got some money
yeah see he's a little of both silly and
rich Hey all right so exactly I'm not
silly at all and just rich pence I was
like suppressing the laughter I can't
believe it okay so yeah I love to
bishops hooray for me but I didn't
promote my points to Queens because he
sacrificed his rook for it otherwise I
have a queen and two bishops then I
thought he was going to play for
stalemate what I still made him that's
all I ever think about when they have no
pieces so I'm never gets telling anybody
you guys might do that you're like up to
Queens all happy and you're not thinking
about sale made you got to think about
sale mate
yeah uh and you still needed no comments
ah
he said yeah ah yeah I had two guys in
the last two years give all their pieces
away and try to get still man I still
ate them no but they tried